[Music]
if there's one thing in the world you
definitely shouldn't worry about it's
that fake Central American migrants Erev
an the xenophobic nationalists on Fox
News have been trying to scare you into
caring about or believing in the whole
thing is made up it's a mirage and even
if it's sort of real it's basically on
the other side of the planet far far
away from here what some of the most
trusted people in America explain why
your fears are ridiculous they're
telling you existential threat to
America it's a bunch of poor refugees a
thousand miles away this group of folks
we don't even know where they are
they're way down there
call this an invasion it might be the
most pathetic invasion of a country in
world history if this were actually an
invasion but of course it's not people
he called invaders even though they were
a thousand miles away the programming on
the caravan was propaganda way down
there a thousand miles away in other
words the caravan is a lot like social
security it's something we might
potentially need to think about someday
but for now everything's totally fine
calm down
what Liars they are in fact parts of
that supposedly distant Caravan have
already made it to the American border
in many of the illegal migrants in it
have already hopped our shotty defenses
and entered our country the famous
people you just watch claim that would
never happen have it admitted they were
wrong intentionally or not they haven't
issued Corrections of course and they
never will the elections over so they're
on for next talking point meanwhile the
torrent continues well despite the
caravan being a myth invented by
President Trump to win a midterm somehow
Univision anchor Enrique Acevedo managed
to find it and he joins us tonight from
Tijuana Mexico Enrique I'm a little bit
confused so last time I checked which
was just a couple of days ago it seems
like that Caravan was in President
Obama's terms a thousand miles away and
they were walking how did they get to
Tijuana the caravan is very real
movement of people thousands of people
around 5000 have already arrived to
Tijuana in the border with San Diego
trucker but it's not a national
emergency or is not and it's not a
threat to the national security of the
United States most of the people that
are part of this Caravan are just
pushing strollers through Mexico their
families women babies they're just going
to get to the US before that you can
request asylum President Trump is making
much much harder before we get to the
subjective part I mean I'm an American
I'll decide whether it's a threat or not
if that's okay I just want to get to the
practical part of this so we were told
by anchors across the spectrum on
television that the caravan was a
thousand miles away they were walking it
was going to be weeks before they got to
our border I wake up this morning and
there they are how'd that happen did
they run or did someone pay buses to
take them up here and you didn't tell us
that part it took them almost a month or
over a month to get from Honduras to the
us-mexico border not all of them have
arrived some of them are still trying to
get to this point talker and yeah some
of them were able to catch a ride and
get on a bus on trailers on the back of
buses carrying chickens and and Peaks
that's how they try to reach the border
one so you're saying that nobody
chartered any buses to bring them up
here because I think we have video
showing chartered buses bringing them up
here and you're there I haven't seen
anyone you don't think there were any
chartered buses whatsoever I haven't
seen anyone charting buses to bring them
to the border I've seen Mexican
authorities for example here in Tijuana
providing transportation from this point
at the border to manatorian
setting Justin oh very close from here
where people are spending the night so
they're being transported in buses from
here to there but not from Oaxaca to the
border okay I don't think that's quite
right you might want to check your facts
in that because it would be physically
impossible for the group to move as a
group on the back of chicken trucks
especially with the strollers you claim
are there when in fact the eyewitness
accounts we have suggest it's
overwhelmingly young unattached men but
you're saying its majority we
they're babies and strollers is that
what you're saying I'm happy to share
the footage with Fox News the footage
from our correspondent patrol traders
who traveled with them in the back of a
bus that usually carries chickens that's
how they got to rights in trailers in
the back of pickup trucks so that's you
know that's the fact that we guess what
I'm saying is what you're engaging in is
propaganda designed to convince people
of something that's not true so I think
we both know that the majority of people
including people we just saw on the tape
moving from Honduras and Guatemala are
men young men without their wives and
children right or you're not going to
admit that I don't think anyone was
questioning the existence of the carven
what they were questioning is the label
of being a national thread some sort of
emergency that needed what's next would
we accept that some troops in Chicago or
in Manhattan I mean okay no but hold on
it's very hard to make rational
decisions about how to respond to
something if you don't know what it is
because everyone on TV is lying to you
and it's really clear that everyone on
TV is lying to us they told us that was
gonna be weeks before this Caravan got
here because they were walking that was
a lie they told us it was mostly women
and children that's a lie they said
there was no one else helping the
caravan get here that was a lie and so
until we get to the facts we can't know
how to respond so let's stop with the
lying and tell us what is actually going
on and you know what as well as I it's
mostly economic migrants looking for
higher wages in the United States I'm
not attacking them but that's the
reality talker there's no organized
effort to try to get these migrants from
Honduras to the border to the us-mexico
border
I know vice-president pence said that
there were forces in Latin America from
the left and Venezuela financing this
and making it some sort of a conspiracy
to undermine the US government but the
reality is that these people are fleeing
Honduras 300 Honduras are live in their
country every day and they're doing it
because the levels of violence and the
levels of extreme poverty that they face
they're so
this is not a monetary on crisis and
again all the governments in both should
act like it okay you're saying I just
want to get you on the record saying
this that there are no groups funded by
governments or big NGOs helping this
group of people move from Central
America to where they are now to wanna
and to get across the river nobody is
helping them it's all organic that's
what you're saying in all our in all our
reporting since this Garvin started not
only this one the others that follow and
that will keep following them we haven't
found any evidence of any government
involved in founding or funding or
financing this effort to try to get
these people from Honduras to the
us-mexico border helped Mexican people
have been kind enough to provide some
humanitarian help but there's no
government or state force behind this
this we all know what's exactly what's
going on I just I just want to have you
on the record so we can invite you back
and we can talk through your previous
claims and compare them to the evidence
that we are in the process of gathering
and I can't wait for that thank you so
much Enrique for joining us tonight from
Tijuana Mexico Thank You Tucker